なんかTwitterでよく“しゃっちょさん”、“しゃっちょさん”って言われるんですよ。
“しゃっちょさん”ってなんか…
うれしいですね。かわいらしいです。
“しゃっちょさん”か。
エクスキュートって処刑って意味ですよ。
はじめ処刑って…
こんにちは。“一番はしっこのレーン、投げにくそう”です。
おかしいでしょ？
あぁ、もうなんか、あれですか？　ご当地キャラみたいな感じで、行けと。
もうこれ、もう他の人ですからね。もう。
MEGWIN(メグウィン)さんじゃないですか。
オレがオレにオンデマンドWEGMIN(ウェグミン)だ。
おい！
ペロペロ番長ってもう、どんなんっすか？もう。
うぇ～みたいなかんじですか？
おかしいでしょ？
オンラインマンってもう、すごい、ど…
どう見たらオンラインマンに？
激萎えナイーブ太郎…
何か…すごい、よくそんなの思いつきますね。
僕、右腕臭くないですよ
うぅ～～～！！
こんにちは！手長猿ｄ…
おかしいでしょ！
はい、というわけで、
まあいろんなコメントがあったんですけど、
何かほかにもね、結構ね、たくさんあったんですよ。
はじフォイっていうのが多かったし、
まあ、きっと僕をマルフォイにしたかったんでしょうね。
はじフォイとか、
あとなんか、
はじめ平社員とか社員とか
そういう感じが多かったんですけど、
僕の新しい名前はですね…
“はじめしゃちょー”です
いや、けど聴いてください。今までとは違いますからね。
やっぱりこう…会社の長って書いたら、
もう、会社の長じゃないですか。
けど僕、会社の長じゃないので、
やっぱ会社の長っていう字を使っちゃだめなんですよ
なので、表記の仕方をですね、
まあ、ふつうに“はじめ”
で、こっちを…
あれです…
ひらがなにします。
“しゃちょー”って、
ほら、
“しゃちょー”って
まあ、こうすることによってね、
もう、“しゃちょー”っていう言葉に会社の長っていう意味をもたなくなって、もう…
なんていうんだろう…
言いたいことわかるっしょ？
会社の長じゃないんですけど“しゃちょー”っていう名前なんです。
なので、
僕のことを…
あの…漢字で言わないでください。
大事なことです、これは。
漢字で呼んだら、
会社でいじめられるんで、ダメですよ。
ひらがなで呼んでいただきたいです。
皆さん本当にコメントありがとうございました。
まあ、基本的にもう、はじめさんって…もうはじめさんって…
い…も…呼べよ。
はじめさんって呼べよ。
仕方ないときだけ…
“しゃちょー”ってつけるみたいな感じで、
今後もいきたいと思うので、
ひらがなの…“はじめしゃちょー”です。
まあ、海外に行くことがあったらね、ローマ字になると思うけど、
またその時は、
よろしくお願いします。
じゃあな！
あっ、そうだたまにね、なんかこうやって、
なんていうんだろう…
コメントを読むことがあるので、
みなさん、よかったらね、また…
コメントとか…
高評価とか…
ぜひまめにして頂けたら、ありがたいです。
じゃっ！